that's been the best part about your San
Diego comic-con experience this year oh
there's been several good parts of it
but I got a coffee shop to donate some
coffee local coffee shop and handed it
out to people in the hall each mine
people who have been waiting out all
night long last night so we passed out
you know fifteen hundred cups of coffee
this morning
Wow college line and that was pretty fun
people had been you know there for 1415
hours all night long so I was the best
reaction you got in the fans Authority
there was all those I'm crying I like I
like it I like seeing them cry I told
him I was going prize oh really yeah yes
what do you want yeah I mean Cass is
dying is his Grace's fading and and he's
unwilling to slidden other angels throat
or cooperate with Metatron in order to
rectify the problem so he's sort of
resigned to his own expiration and he is
hell-bent on trying to fix Dean and that
project for him is what he's putting his
energy into because he feels like
there's nothing he can do for himself
there you go
super fun about playing last year was a
very I really liked doing that human ark
that was great for the character that
was something that from the beginning I
have had hoped that they would do with
Castiel there was a moment in season 5
when he almost became human for a second
and then we didn't really play it out so
it was nice to really get a chance to
have cast be human for a few episodes
and also it you know changes the
character because now he has experienced
what it's like to be a human and he can
empathize with them much better energy
joking like years ago about the musical
episode like hypothetically yeah so how
excited are you for this I'm excited
it's kind of it's going to be good it's
going to be good
there is definitely a mute the 200th
episode is a what did what is Jeremy
allowed us to say it's Jerry a musical
ish or musical esque
I don't know I haven't read the script
yet so I don't know exactly what's going
to work we're still on the second
episode so that's the fifth episode so
in little ways off to sing in light like
I do sing in life do you are you uh are
you a carry opener no I don't think
that's a thing yeah I've never really
that made me carry with you for some
reason that is a shame though isn't it
we're gonna have to rectify the second
act yeah well what does oh sorry going
what's a song that you can't help but
sing along here like maybe journey's
don't stop well these days it's stuff
more along the lines of Puff the Magic
Dragon and Frosty the Snowman and stuff
like that because that's a that's
permeating my consciousness on a daily
basis
you know we were just talking about
guest stars yeah they're a bunch of them
we would think that the show has gotten
is pretty successful now and there are a
lot of there are a lot of kind of Big
Shot actors who are also fans of the
show who would just for fun come and do
an episode but we haven't really taken
advantage of that yet we haven't done
they call it stunt casting in the
business we haven't really done much of
that I think it'd be fun to do a little
bit I would love to have Shatner on the
show great whitney's that blow you away
when I mean I know that there's stuff on
the scene but did that blow you away he
starts reaching out and talking about
this show totally totally blew me away
blew me away you know I'm running this
scavenger hunt the greatest
international scavenger hunt the world
has ever seen
Gish was which Shatner is participating
in he put together a team and dissipated
it is participating in it which is so
cool and totally unexpected for those of
you who didn't make it to comic-con this
year you didn't miss anything was
totally boring
you're better off where you were you
made the right choice totally nothing
happened there was no one here it was a
it was a bust
you